an impenetrable physical
tall powerful beautiful southern border
wall
[Applause]
should we build the wall they're
bringing drugs
they're bringing crime they're rapists
and some
i assume are good people donald trump
recently traveled to the u.s mexico
border near san diego to tour prototypes
of the big beautiful wall that was a
centerpiece of his presidential campaign
trump supporters came out to express
their enthusiasm
why do you support the wall it's like if
you had a kennel
with dogs i'm not saying that we're all
dogs or anything like that but
are we going to let them all run in the
field trump has requested 25 billion
dollars just to build the wall
and independent estimates put the price
tag even higher trump saving a lot of
money so
nobody should be complaining about the
cost everything that comes with illegals
and drugs and other things there that's
also expensive
annual maintenance would run at least
hundreds of millions of dollars on top
of the billions already being spent to
expand border patrol personnel and
technology
mexico will pay for the wall
actually it won't i'm not going to pay
for that
[ __ ] wall which leaves american
taxpayers on the hook
there's a lot of people here who are
criminals drug dealers
gang members we've seen example after
example of people killing people
and then nothing's happening but there
are good people too so we also have to
make sure that we're cracking down on
the bad
rather than the good do you think that
there's any merit to the argument that
instead of spending you know 25 billion
on a wall we could better use those
resources if we're actually just
targeting the bad actors
this is an investment on its own and any
investment is going to cost money
and of course the initial investment's
going to be huge as a border patrol
agent
i can tell you walls do work the u.s has
erected hundreds of miles of fencing and
other barriers in the last 30 years and
more than quintupled the number of
border patrol agents on the ground
in addition to installing high-tech
sensors and cameras and using military
drones to patrol
and yet coyotes and drug cartels have
out-innovated authorities
using tunnels planes drones ships
catapults car ramps and even specially
built submarines
so how would this new wall be different
you're dealing with people who will find
a way
around but i think one of the most
powerful things we can do is create
deterrence if you build a 30-foot wall
you need a 31-foot ladder right like
what do you say people say
they got to come over the other side how
about having they have a rope
i favor regardless of what fence there
needs to be razor wire
if they're staring at a wall a razor
wire
they can't cross something concrete
where also
you're not having people digging holes
under the wall either because people can
dig holes under walls too it doesn't
have to solve all our problems but we
have to start
moving towards the solution and i don't
think you can have it without a wall
but would a new physical wall actually
accomplish what supporters hope for
the majority of unauthorized immigrants
to the us don't walk across the border
they show up with temporary visas and
then overstay them and these days more
mexican migrants have been exiting the
country than coming in this is the land
of the american dream we want people to
come in here
but they want people to do it the right
way like my family did when they came
from mexico and cuba
but for mexican immigrants getting a
visa is nearly impossible
in 2018 the quota is just 25 000 people
and there are nearly 1.3 million on the
waiting list
i don't want our country to change to
the point where
it is not what it is now you're from
iraq right so people who are pro-wall
pro-trump
might say well people from iraq are
changing the nature of our country right
so
do you worry if if we put caps on legal
immigration that people like you
who are immigrating and trying to do the
right thing won't have that opportunity
okay you gotta care about american
citizens first
yes there is a lot of people in my
original country that wants to come to
the united states
but i am an american right now it's you
gotta look at what
for the american people first ironically
expanding fencing and reducing guest
workers over the past few decades has
led to more unauthorized immigrants
staying in the u.s
because the barriers didn't stop
entrants but they did raise the costs of
going back over the border
an exhaustive study by princeton
sociologist douglas massey concluded
there are now over 5 million more
illegal residents than there would have
been if policies under ronald reagan had
been maintained
rather than talking about putting up a
fence make it possible for them to come
here legally with a work permit
and then while they're working and
earning here they pay taxes here
and when they go on to go back they can
go back and they can cross and open the
border both ways
only about a third of borderland is
owned by the federal government with
arrests split between states native
american tribes
and private landowners there's people
along the border that would have to have
you know part of their property taken
do you think that you're concerned about
that i'm not concerned about it maybe
the ranchers might be right there you're
all you're all of a sudden going to that
land-grabbing thing
it would require some takings right
innocent americans would be caught up in
immigration rights it's the art of the
deal
you know it's you know people want
change people want change
building a wall along the entire 2000
mile border also poses practical
challenges
a double barrier like those that already
exist near san diego and around the rio
grande
needs to be porous so that flood waters
can escape and americans can access
their land
if we can build the atomic bomb in three
or four years we can build a fence
what year was the wall of china built
there's a lot of walls around the world
but trump's proposed wall presents
unique challenges in a world in which
most illegal immigrants don't walk
across the border and not a single
terrorist ever has
in which small businesses rely on
immigrant labor and in which average
americans could be hurt by increased
prices or violations of their civil
liberties
does it make sense to spend tens of
billions of dollars on this particular
wall
it's at least a symbol that we are
willing to define where our land ends
and
mexico begins america needs to be
america first
like point blank